é a rainha galera seguinte há uma semana
um pouco atrás do filho cirurgia na
garganta retirar as famílias já consegue
falar e tal só que ainda dói um pouco
assim sai a gravar os meus vídeos
normais que eu gravo não sei se vocês
sabem mas é assim uns 20 minutos 25
minutos quase meia hora falando assim
não consigo falar muito tempo vai ficar
sem filho vou mostrar pra vocês música
novo é o campo por pouco tempo e na
próxima quarta em vídeo novo normal como
sempre eles a minha volta de cada estilo
vamos nessa
já eu passar a mão no teu cabelo até
você dormir e quando tiver só bateu o
desespero
você sabe eu tô aqui só tomar cuidado
que eu todo seu lado mas você não me
quer só pra te imagina que loucos etá no
sufoco me procura de novo e eu não to
que mina se liga que eu tô aprendendo a
morrer pra mim você eu já vi essa senha
morena você só vai na valor quando me
perder passar a manter o cabelo você
dormir quanto tinha pego sol bater um
desespero
o sábio to aqui só tomar cuidado e todo
seu lado mas você não me quer só para ti
imagina que logo você tá no sufoco me
procura de
o povo e eu não tô aqui mim e disse que
eu tô aprendendo a morrer pra você e eu
eu já vi essa cena morena você só vai
dar valor quando me perder todo mundo
mais uma vez só isso que eu tô
aprendendo a mãe correr pra ver você e
eu nunca vi essa cena morena você só vai
dar valor quando me perder
se você tiver curtir a música se daquele
gostei também lembrando que hoje não
teve vitor normal porque eu não consigo
gravar por muito tempo com essa voz aqui
que começa a doer então gravou a música
que é rapidinho três minutos para não
ficar sem vídeo você está no facebook
agora você já sabe que se clique em
curtir se você está no twitter agora faz
sabe que esse quem retuitar que é para a
música passar por mais gente e quarta
feira agora vídeo normal que também pode
deixar que eu gostei como um sinal de
melhora sair o windows em minhas outras
músicas que vocês ouvirem aí mas outras
músicas pra vocês ouvirem aqui na tela
se você quiser valeu e nice bp